The attorney
representing Trump
in the Justice Department
probe into the classified documents
found at Mar
a Lago
took highly detailed notes
about their conversations.
And sources tell CNN
the notes included details
about Trump's desire
to push back to fight the Justice
Department effort through subpoena.
To recover those documents, those notes.
This is the important part
now in the hands of the special counsel.
Katelyn Polantz is here to break that down
for us.
Their evidentiary value,
I assume, is rather large.
Yeah.
So, John,
you have a criminal investigation
and what is crucial
in any criminal investigation
is how good is your evidence?
The evidence here
appears to be very good.
It is very detailed
to the point where members of the Trump
team were surprised
at how detailed these notes are.
And these are notes
that speak to exactly
what the Justice Department
wants to do as they investigate
whether or not
Donald Trump himself
was trying
to obstruct their investigation.
So in May of 20, 22,
he and his attorney will
receive the subpoena
saying, you got to give back
all the classified records
that you have in your possession.
Anything marked
with a classification on it,
give it back to the grand jury.
And then these notes are Evan Corcoran's
as a defense attorney,
and they cover
detailed conversations
directly between Evan Corcoran.
Donald Trump,
the types of conversations
that when the Justice Department
sought these notes,
when they went to court to fight
to get access to them,
they believed
would show Donald Trump
trying to commit a crime.
And they have these notes
now, and they are
quite, quite
significant in the fact
that they would be so detailed.
And we also are getting a little snippet
of what the substance of these notes are.
And we can see that Donald Trump,
or at least we're hearing
from our sources
that Donald Trump
was raising the possibility,
do we have to comply with this subpoena?
We don't know how that fits.
But it certainly does factor
into this obstruction investigation.
Shan Wu is still with us.
Help us understand where it might fit.
And again, we have to be careful.
But you have detailed
notes from an attorney, a good attorney.
And so if you're asking
if you're telling your client,
the former president,
we have this subpoena,
the subpoena is valid.
We have to comply with the subpoena.
I assume that the attorney
is walking through this.
If you get a response from the client
saying no, don't do it.
What does that tell you?
Well,
it tells you that the client doesn't
want to comply with that subpoena
and maybe try to hide something.
I think the critical aspect to me here,
and we don't know this
yet from the details,
is whether or not
this is evidence
that Trump
was basically admitting to his attorney.
I know I have classified documents
and I don't want to give them back.
That would be a very helpful thing
to the Justice Department now.
Trump's defense to
this is going to be I'm
just asking for legal advice
and I want to know,
can I push back on the subpoena or not?
I will say one thing.
It strikes me as a little bit unusual
that Corcoran's notes are this detailed.
When I was a prosecutor,
prosecutors different their styles.
But sometimes you don't
want to take a whole lot of notes
because you're always worried
that somebody may try to get them
to question, you know,
what kind of contemporaneous thoughts
were going on there.
So it's possible
Corcoran was doing this
as a little bit of a safety
net for himself,
knowing that this is a difficult client
who is kind of volatile.
He may have been really documenting
his contemporaneous notes at the time.
That level of detail
reminds me more of an FBI
agents notes than it does.
And also notes at this moment,
Corcoran is talking to
his client,
Donald Trump,
about collecting documents at Mar a Lago.
And when he
hands over an envelope in June,
which is the end of these notes,
the Justice Department got
he has an envelope.
It has 38 documents
with classified markings on it.
And he tells the Justice Department
at this point,
we know this from court filings
that he believes
there was no other classified documents
at Mar a Lago.
Obviously, there were hundreds of more.
And so the justice system
is trying to figure out,
well, who knew about that
and how did this happen,
if this attorney performed this search,
having detailed notes
about what
those conversations were between
Evan Corcoran
and Donald Trump,
perhaps could answer that question
or bring them closer to an answer.
And Evan Corcoran,
to wrap
this up, it's also been before
the grand jury, correct?
Yes. Right.
So this gets interesting.
Fascinating, complicated.